I want to address the blurring problem
because one of the concerns that comes
out of the literature is that for people
who blur impact investing with pure
philanthropy it is shifting pure
philanthropy into that space and as
Julia said in the earlier part of this
two-part conversation we still need to
maintain a level of philanthropy that
isn't getting a financial return are you
helping people to make it very clear
what the choices are and the different
endpoints of both of those I think we
would be responsible if we weren't
because I think what's implicit in your
question and what is dangerous is that
and as Julia was alluding to there are
many socially orientated businesses that
were it not for philanthropic capital
simply would not get to the stage where
even the most early stage risk hungry
impact investment vehicle would take the
blinders bit of notice of them so I
think there's a onus is on us as the
community to emphasize the importance of
both aspects but again I think it goes
back to helping to educate them on the
return both financial and non-financial
dimensions that they can expect from
both buckets if you will